[Music]
welcome to the AI the future of us a
podcast Style video series that explores
the ways AI is shaping our feature and
how we can prepare for the changes that
lie ahead I'm your host Brad seconder
and today we are joined by Dave
Nettleton product lead and data
analytics thank you for here being here
today Dave
thank you for that excited to be here
and look forward to chatting with you
today thank you so let's start and can
you let's start with your background and
expertise can you tell us a little bit
about your background in the field of
data and Ai and what you have been doing
yeah yeah for sure so um so actually I I
started many years ago with an undergrad
in maths
um which became then a PhD actually in
artificial intelligence
and from there it went on to be
um an academic at the University uh in
the UK where we were funding a lot of
our work through uh projects we were
doing
um building telephony uh
um inquiry systems doing text analysis
um and we actually eventually spun a
company out from the University to do
that we uh
um built all kinds of interesting uh
products we grew we were acquired by a
company in the valley and then building
uh intelligent chat Bots for the
internet this was in the late 90s we
then blew up with them actually as part
of the.com Boom which point
um I came over to America uh started on
the data part of my journey joined
Microsoft worked on databases uh data
and analytics uh for many years worked
on storage for a while some of the early
days of azure and then that brought me
to Google seven years ago
um where I've been working on storage
and data analytics and more recently now
bringing back some of those AI
capabilities uh into uh into the
products so yeah uh been great to just
work with so many customers through that
Journey
while it's amazing our journey is fine
enough it's very very similar because I
started with the you know PhD in Ai and
move into Data but I haven't been as
successful as you have been so far so
let's see and and can you share some of
the data and AI developments that you
have witnessed your awesome career as
well yeah yeah yeah well you know I mean
if I go back you know there was there's
been kind of traditionally two ways to
do artificial intelligence right sort of
the rule-based techniques and then the
stats based the neural networks
techniques
um and you know well so there was always
this sort of tension between the two
because rules base is very good in a
particular domain but really struggled
with ambiguity when you would step
outside of that stats based really good
at dealing with ambiguity but then
struggles when you want to be something
that's really specific
um and for me it's been really
interesting to see sort of the evolution
over the last few decades because uh you
know stats-based techniques were so
limited that rules base was actually you
know a mechanism for a while that many
people pursued but as processing power
improved algorithms improved and the
amount of data available uh improved
then the ability to deal with uh like
really scale stats-based approaches were
really good and then
um you know the one big step forward on
the NL side was obviously it was the
introduction of the the T in uh uh uh
the transform right which really helped
with some of this better understanding
of the ambiguity and text which is
phenomenally difficult to deal with
um and you know it's really interesting
I remember back in the day we used to
talk about recall and precision there's
much cooler names now like hallucination
which I think is far much cooler right
but I think there's a super interesting
opportunity now to Britain really marry
the best of these two best practices
right using things like llms and gen AI
to manage some of the ambiguity but then
tying it together with specific domain
knowledge that you have about your
organization just to help refine the
accuracy of answers so very exciting
time you know the the step functions and
processing power and algorithms coupled
with the
um uh the amount of data is just now led
to this leapfrogen capability which
we're seeing play out now over the last
year and it's interesting right and I
think your spot on it is all about the
three things that the data and the
algorithms but also the compute and
which what we are seeing I think is that
the data and AI has been you know treat
us to separate disciplines in the past
and they're coming together and also we
are seeing the other and convergence of
the AI and you know compute which is
coming to HPC uh to deal with all of
this and scale is getting much bigger
right but I also want to you know
understand a little bit around what are
the you know the challenges that you see
closing the scap that I mentioned around
the data engineering and data analytics
side with the machine learning because
you have been very experience in both of
them how can we bring them together
yeah so great question
um you know so one of the challenges
always in data and analytics has been
that you have to move data between
different systems for different types of
specialist processing right so in the in
the traditional days customers would run
transactional systems that have an oltp
system they would ETL data out of that
into a data warehouse they would shape
it in a particular format to answer the
reporting questions that they knew and
that was how businesses ran for many
years running reports to retroactively
ask questions on their business right
and this created you know data silos
um uh very well governed data but it was
very siled right
um and what customers were finding is
like but there is so much more you know
the the you know the volume of data the
variety of data that was really really
uh increasing astronomically that led to
a completely different paradigms for
like something like uh mapreduce right
which ultimately led to Hadoop which
allowed for very large scale scaled out
processing to happen
um which was again phenomenal for doing
things at super large scale it couldn't
be done before
which was you know you couldn't do in
the other world where you had typically
had these scaled up systems but the
challenge was then it led to this
completely ungivened mess right
um so so I I think there's there's a
couple of things that the cloud has
really enabled right so number one is
it's enabled
um customers to uh truly separate
compute from Storage right so you can
scale compute separately from Storage
you don't have to buy a fixed size
system operate it and then when it runs
out of scale move data to some other
system and optimize that you can truly
separate compute from Storage which is
very very powerful and then secondly is
then bringing the algorithms to the data
right and you know this is again
something that the cloud uniquely
enables if you have that compute storage
separation and you can bring algorithms
to data that's Unthinkable on premises
you know you mentioned a you could build
a very high performance scaled up super
optimized system but then that's it like
you have to like that's the only thing
that you can operate everything else
you're copying data two or copying data
from right the beauty of the cloud and
this huge step function forward we have
is this the separation of compute and
storage and the
um the ability to bring compute to that
data now that's played out uh
particularly well for products like
bigquery right which is a really large
scale data warehousing uh products and
platform
um but as we carry forward into the
world of um uh you know Ai and more
recently gen AI you know that that whole
Paradigm now have been able to combine
the best of structured data that's
represented and defined in a in a
well-defined way that your engines can
operate over and Trust to do things like
real level and column level security and
as we think about you know object tables
out in something like GCS where we can
bring unstructured data I'm sure we'll
come back to that one
um then
um you know we have a single way now to
manage all of this data and again you
know we can bring those ml algorithms to
Bear over that we've even built it into
the product bigquery with a uh a feature
called bigquery ml which you know lets
you run things in the warehouse but also
tie into you know your own and
third-party models too
and and I think you're right and within
that so one of the things that happened
is you know I spend a lot of time in
supercomputers and AI but it didn't
become mainstream right it was very
Niche at the end of the day it required
lots of you know very specialized people
to you know operate them and I think
cloud made that really you know more
mainstream as you alluded into uh what
are the data governance challenges that
you have been saying within this you
know as well because now we are bringing
unstructured data which is much harder
to understand what's inside because it
you know there is no structure around
that you cannot look into certain cons
and such yes you can look and search
into that but at the same time you are
bringing different types of data from a
lot more systems as well which you might
not have that close and tight control
around that and you might also not have
that you know annotated business
metadata around that explaining that to
you as well so how do you thing that
will be you know able to deal with all
of that as well
yeah I mean you know and I'm glad you
mentioned one extra thing about the
benefits of cloud right which is that
sort of self-service nature that's been
hugely empowering for many organizations
they don't need to set up infrastructure
to get going now the challenge there is
like now many people in an organization
can get going and so now they start to
think about governance lineage these
have been problems that you know
companies have looked to solve uh for
many years and I think they're going to
see an additional level of
um uh interest there because as we start
to think about you know I talked about
that workflow of
um uh you know analyzing data with a an
llm model and dealing with ambiguity but
then perhaps refining it with business
data you know customers are going to
want to be able to understand the the
sort of the lineage of not just the data
but of the decision making that went
into this answer it's like okay I I ask
a question
um you know what are my annual sales
number pops up okay next question where
did that data come from right and can
you explain how it was derived to me
right those are the sorts of experiences
that we want to enable where you know a
completely different class of user can
start to ask some of those you know
relatively simple to phrase but
incredibly difficult to answer
potentially questions
um so we need to be able to have you
know things like lineage data quality
metadata governance kind of baked into
this as a first-class system and
sometimes when we talk about like the
different like the
um the journey that customers are on the
customer maturity model sometimes we
call it sometimes we start with like
customers might start in data silos data
is siled in different places and
different systems you don't even know
and can't even see across them right
then we you know then there's the
concept of a data mesh right where
there's a single you know definitive
namespace copy for your data right with
additional you know metadata and
business governance things on that right
but but that that's great but ultimately
you want to get to the last stage which
is uh data apps right like the you want
only get value out of your data when
you're running analytics against your
data right so how can we make it easy
then to sort of Leverage all of that
foundation and build applications that
are super easy to deploy to use to fully
operationalize run automatically run on
your behalf you know they they warn you
if they're starting to drift based on
parameters that you set right like
there's a whole new world of
operationalization and optimization here
is and tying it back to lineage and data
quality and governance will be very
important because if we want to meet a
new set of users and might you know I
think when customers came to the cloud
you know the data people I talk to now
are data Engineers data scientists
um and data analysts right I don't
really talk to database administrators
anymore right like like their roles have
changed right they're now doing finops
or workload management they're doing
different higher level governed things
for their own organization right and
what I think we have the opportunity for
is pretend is also now to enable new
classes of users to do not everything
but some of the things that data
Engineers data scientists
um uh data analysts do in a much
simplified now user-based experience but
in order to have the privilege of doing
that we have to be able to explain what
the results are and where they came from
and then and that's the key point for
having the data governance really
applying as you said starting from the
way that where the data is generated it
propagates all the way through into your
ml applications now this is where all
the you know X viability comes into the
play as well because if you understand
all your data sources where they're
coming from it is much easier to
understand you know and explain what it
is doing as well right do you have more
control over that but with that with how
do you see the data warehousing with
llms in mind evolving as well you added
into you know all of this person is
coming to the number of ways that llms
can help and that's not the only way as
well right so what's your views on that
yeah yeah yeah no great question so so
you know applying AI to data has always
been something that we've been you know
certainly from the bigquery perspective
thinking about and working on for a
quite some time now and I think Jenny I
is going to be transformational for many
businesses some parts of that Journey
though are incremental to what we're
doing and there's some things that are
sort of you know fresh ground for us
right some of the things that we you
know think about incremental he's like
we want to have the best data platform
to build your AI Solutions on right like
all AI is driven by data right and
um we want to make sure we have the best
pipelines the best data platform and the
best algorithms so that you can build
the applications that you want on top as
efficiently and as effectively as
possible right so you know we're looking
at things like
integrating with uh you know llm apis
that vertex AI offers again you don't
have to move your data you can just call
directly even directly from within a SQL
query I remember the first time I used
bigquery ml within you know 30 lines of
SQL I'd like created a training set like
created a training set and a test set
I'd split the data build the model uh
trained it tested it it was like wow
that's amazing 30 lines of a sequel with
an arima plus model super simple but I
was like wow like that would be
a whole other thing for me to accomplish
outside of this experience
um so so I think just making it very
easy for customers to uh use these
models with their data right
um is one huge thing now the other part
I think which is very interesting is
like how can we use llms to improve the
experiences of our customers right so
this Building Solutions but we can also
use llms to improve experiences for our
customers right and you know we've
announced some of what I would call as
like the starting point of these with
things like chat assist uh code assist
um to help you know data people the data
analyst data scientists um data
Engineers just be more productive in
their language and their documentation
and finding answers right now I think we
can go even further with that and start
to really think about like higher level
automated experiences where huh maybe I
don't need to be now
um you know manually searching for data
Maybe the the system is able to
understand the queries that have been
ran in my organization before and people
who like me because they're in my group
I'll have the same title and I'm able to
prompt me with ideas for getting started
because sometimes one of the hardest
problems is just frankly getting started
someone will send you a giant data
catalog and a big gnarly query and it's
like okay now I've got it from here
figure out I forgot the right data set
and the right like no no like let's
clear all that out of the way and just
make it very easy for customers to get
started with a very simple simple
experience and then if they need to fall
through into a more uh sophisticated
tooling then you know that path is there
but my my hope would be you know we can
start to solve like 80 of those basic
use cases with just a very simple
experience
and I think that's an important point
right because that 80 percent still
requires some you know human interaction
to make it and up you know make it 100
right so and we are not really
eliminating you know the human element
in this as you put through we are
assisting the humans right and we are
assisting different personas or
achieving that so at the same time we
hear a lot of organizations you know
going through this journey uh but
they're also failing to uh in in you
know certain locations and this has been
very well documented by Lotto analyst
organizations as well right to uh
demonstrate the value that particularly
the generative AI brings to the
organizations right because it is at
another hump you know it is a trade-off
how much effort that you are putting in
harmony how much resources you are using
and what value that you are getting as
well so what value do you think does a
generative AI bring to organizations and
where do you see that leading to yeah I
mean one of my one of our customers put
this was really nicely they said look my
role there's only two things I can do I
can save money or I can make money right
like that's what I have to figure out
for my business right and you know Jenny
I kind of plays into into both of these
maybe more so at the moment in the
applications we're seeing on the
creative side right like if we can make
a broader group of people more creative
able to answer more questions more
quickly they will be more productive in
answering whichever questions they have
whether it be trying to analyze cost
saving opportunities in a business or
new Revenue generation opportunities in
a business right
um you know it's
um the ROI is always uh it is always a
super important thing to think about as
you think about like kind of that
measurable impact and this is where we
have to think about how we are able to
better sort of attribute and understand
the full costs of running some of these
systems right so that people can
um uh really understand the uh the ROI
you know for the Jenny I part was
somewhat in the early stages of that
right there's you know entire industries
that are nervous about like how the path
is going to go forward for them they
tend to be more on the sort of the like
pure creative side
um and I think I think the capabilities
and what we've seen so far in terms of
helping people discover try generate
explore just with the creative process
um I think it's very powerful so I think
there's a I think there's a lot of
productivity opportunities here and what
I you know I I always remember examples
when I go talk to a customer and I'm
like okay so you have a business problem
to solve how do you do it and it's like
well we take somebody from the business
team we bring a data scientist together
and we bring a data engineer together
and we put them together in a room and
then they talk about how they're going
to solve this problem and I'm like first
of all I say congratulations that you
have those people in your organization
and have fought to organize them and ask
them these questions because like that
is actually skills like availability of
skills
um uh that have domain business data
knowledge is very hard right so but you
know there's only a limited number of
those people and they can only work and
interact on so many projects at the same
time right so how can we really simplify
those interactions so that there's much
more you know sort of I'd love to get to
a much more sort of self-service model
but one that is kind of governed and
controlled it's like you know okay you
can do whatever you want Within These
parameters right you can run these
models but you know we're going to
manage the cost or the what the amount
of CPU resource that can use because
there's other business critical reports
that need to run at this time you can
have access to this data but not this
data right yep you can put this in
production but only run it at this kind
of uh scale you know if it really starts
to scale then we might come back and
talk to you about how to do that right
so lots of opportunities there uh in
terms of understanding the r in the ROI
and it's interesting right and also uh
the opportunity cost is important as
well because you know the Ryland
focusing on the projects that will add
the most value to your organization
sometimes you can go into some rabbit
holes and it takes lots of time for you
to get out of it as well so sometimes we
really need to experiment you know and
fail fast and see what what value there
will be as well so yeah and I want to
you know look ahead a little bit and you
know Ai and data warehousing in
particular so what do you believe is the
most exciting in a potential
applications and uses of this that we
have yet to see right there's lots of
noise lots of things coming through but
what we haven't heard do you think
yeah I mean like at the moment we're
really sort of thinking about how can we
improve sort of individual productivity
right
um and I think when we can start to
think about how can we really help
organizations really scale and operate
their businesses in new ways I think we
really then start to sort of break
through into sort of new levels of uh
scale and uh opportunity because
ultimately we're trying to help people
experiment faster right and I loved how
you phrased in that last question is
like customers are trying to experiment
right and you've got to kind of come in
with that experiment mindset and if
experiments are hard you're not going to
do many right but if experiments are
easy you're going to do lots and if you
can check if they're failing fast great
right that's you can then iterate and
iterate and iterate and if we can help
customers through that Journey whether
they're doing that for you know product
recommendations normally detection like
all the kinds of opportunities that we
have for I mean not just gen AI but sort
of classic AI use cases as well I think
that's very powerful because I think
there's a lot we can still do there and
I do think some of the sort of the
retrieval augmented generation workflows
are going to be particularly interesting
um as customers look to Leverage The hey
I've got the the ambiguity uh handled
now but now I need to refine it and then
I think the other thing which is going
to really be interesting is okay imagine
companies are successful at doing this
right they're going to want to ruin it
at really large scale right and then and
then the economics of like like really
start to kick in right you know calling
a couple of llm apis to test okay fine
calling hundreds of thousands an hour
right really starts to
um you know really start to make you
think about hey what are the economics
of operating these systems at scale
right so then starting to find ways that
um you know we can save customers from
calling hundreds of thousands of API
calls to do something right like with
Vector indexes we can do clustering and
classification you know you can create a
vector index on say an image once
started in one in a vector index and you
can then run clustering nearest neighbor
on it
um and that's you know really helping
customers sort of get to scale points
with this as they get through the
experimentation phase
and and I really like the way that you
know you portray as well because now we
are using generative AI to create all
those Vector indexes to be able to go
and search for it but while as we are
searching we are using more classical
you know AI to apply nearest neighbor
and then find out what are the you know
how did that relationships works as well
right so and and I think that's a that's
a very very good way of putting it so
and my last question is what advice
would you give to individuals and
businesses who are really looking to
prepare a future right it is changing
and AI is going to play an even more
significant role
yeah I mean I you just have to be
willing to uh it's in it's for me very
heavily about investing in your people
and your organization right so help your
people experiment like give them the
tools give them the permission give them
the space give them the encouragement
let them fail let them learn right
create a learning environment that they
can
um uh you know really like develop their
own skills in the context of your
business right that's a great investment
in in your your organization's talent
pool it's actually a Founder
organizations do this actually attract
talent because of this as well right
it's a virtuous cycle so if you can
really get into that uh and encourage
that sort of experimentation cycle then
that is
um that is that is very very powerful
yes in Akron and I think both of us
comes more with that science and you
know engineering backgrounds and that is
naturally you know we've learned uh you
know as robs if you like that you have
to test and fail and iterate right so
that's the only way to get success and I
I quite like as well thank you really
for joining us today Dave it has been
incredibly insightful to hear your
thoughts on the impact and effective
user Ai and we look forward to seeing
how AI will continue to shape the world
around us and hope our viewers will be
inspired to invest potential and
opportunities
thank you very much really enjoyed
chatting today
[Music]